what will I talk about that's a good
question
I believe tropical curves right so I'm
going to talk about computation
oh
tropical curves
using homophobic continuation and that's
joint work with
uh honors Jensen
Joseph and you
I'm gonna follow
the passionate recommendation of one of
the organizers
and give the total board talk I also
believe that less is more
that's why we have eight talks a day
instead of a dozen
um
so let me um
cancel your talk
all right
that would work
but let me into entertain you further
consider curve
there's a curve in C and it's a complex
curve
so I should tell that uh this project
um
well we start talking about the idea
maybe about three or four years ago and
there are many people to thank for
talking to us in particular we talked
about this with Mikhail passare uh back
in Sweden in maybe three years ago and
that and what Mikhail would do
would uh apply to this
the following map
so suppose your coordinates here are X1
through xn
they do get maps
into log of the absolute values
of
X1 through xn
so you get something in the space r n
and that something would look well okay
this something would be called amoeba so
we are in the world of biology here
okay I think I do enough
is there an eraser right there okay
so what you should imagine
let me draw some holes for the dramatic
effect so what you should imagine is
this body
in RN
and one way to define a tropical
uh
tropical curve so this is called an
amoeba
people
one way to define a tropical curve
is
to take well let's say I have an ideal
defining the original curve and let's
say it's in C The Joint all these
variables
uh the tropicalization of that is gonna
be
the limit
the limit when T goes to Infinity of 1
over t
script A of I where a of I is this
amoeba I drew
foreign
okay
so what what is that said
I'm sorry
blog based in this case
log base T yeah it's the same thing as
if you would take the uh if you change
the base of the log you can you can do
this instead well what what happens in
this picture it sort of shrinks and
moves a little bit and maybe you get
something like this
okay so this would be a
raise
with integers slops slopes emanating
from the origin
okay so that's what Mikhail passari
would do
what
benstrom falls down mclagan
would do in their book
mostly
is different definition
they would take
T of I to be the set of W's that are in
RN such that the initial ideal
with the weight w
contains no monomials
say exactly what a of I is because I got
a little confused with the discussion a
i is the image of this curve so this is
a two-dimensional real object that Maps
into two-dimensional real thing with
boundary
in Orange yeah the log put your favorite
base
and you fix that and divide by two
so it's the same map
the same map for all T and then
it seems
it doesn't change this particular
remember doesn't change I'm just
taken this limit
set limit
how does he play a role in a of I
otherwise the limit is just the constant
AI
noise that go to Infinity
okay try it
try it on the computer maybe I've
actually never tried it uh
so maybe just to
example
let's do the colon curve
one plus x one cubed plus x squared
is going to be our X2 squared is going
to be our ideal
and that will look that would be some of
the Curve
and uh in C2
and uh
of course it Maps into something like
this
so you will have the slope uh two three
I mean the ray two three given by A
Primitive Vector to three in the
integers and here you will have minus E
2 minus
okay so the way to compute this curve
well here it's easy you can draw a
newton polotope
and
it will look like this
and you would compute uh the outer
normal to the Newton polotope of this
one equation and get all the initial
ideals that do not contain monomials in
more General and I'm going to pick
another color to write it
in a more General case you would use
software
by aners Janssen it's called G fan
and it does it for you
on small problems on large problems and
sometimes on very large problems but on
very very large problems with fails
so forget about this definition
uh
well
what we try to do
is experiment with a very
uh very naive idea so
remember there is an amoeba floating
around here
so I'm just drawing the boundary of it
that limits to this tropical curve
so what I would do is let's say
take one tentacle of it
and try to explain this idea in pictures
well uh what what what a numerical
algebraic geometer would do to any
picture he or she would slice it
so we would like to slice this
with uh with
let's call it uh
which is gonna be
just a set
just a set of points capital x I'll use
capital x for this log coordinates
where X
dot V is equal to C
where B is the normal to this
hyperplane
and well for Simplicity integer
oh what do I get in the slice in the
slice well this is a full-bodied thing
so in the slice I get
a segment
but if I do take two slices
that are parallel
I get two segment two segments and
perhaps I don't want to compute points
uh the full segments but I would like to
sample some points in the segments
So to that end
I would introduce
the ideal
I the small C which is going to be I
Plus
the ideal defined by x to the power of V
minus C
where I make sure that the small C
using the relationship with the Big C
which is the most natural one
uh C Capital C is going to be log of the
absolute values
okay
well
now I'm in a situation where I can
compute
so
I can compute
Zero Dimensional variety which is the
variety defined by IVC
that will give me only several points so
let's say if this is my
C
then it will give me a several points on
this slice
but then I'm gonna create a Hamada peel
that will uh continue to see
zero
so consider homography
C of s where as
goes from zero to one
in such a way that the log of the
absolute value of C increases or
non-decreases
then it guarantees that you stay in the
same tentacle and you would end up
well there are some paths that feed you
here
so follow
the hematopia
us
and
finally
what you would do you would just compute
the differences
between the end points
and uh
in number three you would take
disguise which are vectors in RN
and process them with your favorite
technique of getting integers out of
real numbers
the favorite Technique we use is LOL
you can read about the paper it's very
simple setup so there you get
your candidate
rings
that later
we might want to do something with so
it's an experimental computation I mean
you you run it many times with many
different parameters and try to get some
set which is the set of integer vectors
that would generate your range and on
the number of black paths since tomorrow
is going to be the multiplicity
yeah it's coming
so it's sort of a multiplicity of a
tentacle there could be many tentacles
by the way in the same direction
uh at this point we are just in block
number zero of this procedure we would
like to find some suspicious rays that
may be candidates for our thing
and actually that was uh like on small
examples we we made an undergraduate who
who did an Ru in Georgia Tech to run
small examples and we saw that it
actually worked Henry Dawn was his name
and Robert Crone who's in the audience
was participating in this
uh discussions so
okay well I mean we can stop here and
declare that for some values of
parameters our thing works and gives us
the correct uh
you do compute the log
yeah so you get the points
uh right so the picture is drawn in the
log coordinates
yeah so just fill in the blanks I have
only
10 more minutes to go
all right so what do we do next uh well
uh
we
we changed the field so instead of C
here I would consider
now the ideal in
the field where the coefficient Suboxone
series
so K is CT
and suppose I do get
a point
well maybe I should redraw this picture
anatomically correct
uh so for this particular example let's
say I get a point
uh W equal to 2 3.
so what what I want to do next is to
consider curves with non-constant
coefficients difficult curves with
non-constant coefficients and do the
same slice
slice through the
uh through the point so here I can take
1 minus one
because
yeah
one minus one as the direction
so
very similarly to this
setup I can Define IV
C of t
which is my I
Plus
x to the V
minus C of t
where C of T is now absorbed series with
the same valuation as where
the degree of C of t
uh
is equal to
well I mean I would have to pick it V
Dot
oh my God
here the degree the degree
the degree of T has to be set to minus
one there are some conventions that are
floating around but basically this what
happens in the picture even the
valuation picture if you pull it back
well the fundamental
theorem the fun theorem of a tropical
geometry
tells you that
the Zero Dimensional ideal
in uh over field K
would have
the following
property if I take the solution to to uh
my ideal so if I if I take W and compute
the multi multiplicity of
tropicalization of let's say some Zero
Dimensional ideal J
it is equal to the number of bizarre
series solutions to uh
to my ideal so this is the number of
Piezo series roots
I should call it zeros
of J with
with valuation
with degree equal to
on W
ow so in the same manner we would
we would do
the following we assume that we can
well I mean we can always move the
picture here in such a way that uh W is
at the origin
Okay so
if I make the transformation that X goes
to X
t to the W uh or minus w
then this point of question is at zero
that means I'm considering because or I
mean the pizoid series zeros are going
to have valuation zero so they're going
to start with the const
constant term and the terms will go up
so each solution will look like uh
each solution will will be
a solution to the let's say if
if this operation is called wave so if
this operation sends
J to J wave then I want to set up a
homography that computes the
computes
I see
the other way around
IV C of
s or let's say c
um
when this uh when this
t
actually goes from
so if you remember the picture from
from Charles's talk then
you will have this parameter
s
that would parameterize a hemota P4 T
that goes towards T equals zero
so let's say I picked some point
um
where my Solutions are regular where in
other words I do get
uh some slice of my bizarre series and
then I want to go to zero and if it's
generic enough then the homography
the Hamilton you have is gonna avoid
is going to avoid singular
points
of the branch cover well it's not going
to avoid
this point if it were singular
but that's okay
I mean that's okay uh from the point of
view of Applied numerical algebraic
geometry
uh yeah I didn't I forgot to mention
that actually in in full uh trueness we
should consider ideals
in the
loron polynomial ring because well
taking logs of zeros is not a kosher
thing
so here
we do have C star to the power 2 or n
and uh
the thing is that perhaps your variety
is gonna have uh other components than
this curve you are interested in
at the coordinate axis and this junk has
to be somehow ignored
so here at T equals zero you're going to
get a very singular Point towards your
driving your homotype to
and I guess uh
well at the end of that homography
you're of course gonna discover the
value of your Piezo series with
valuation zero which which are constant
coefficients of your bizarre series and
that would be exactly the multiplicity
the multiplicity of the rate if that
multiplicity is zero you have no rate
okay well there are
several uh
I'm gonna skip
skip the part where I explain to you how
to actually stop this computation how to
stop guessing
uh but let me point out that
the toughest part of this was
application of software we actually had
to apply all numerical well not all but
at least three packages of numerical
algebraic software available and The
crucial I mean you you may think that uh
why do we keep programming different
implementations of multiple continuation
using bertinia enough
well there are some features that are
not present in all of them so we
actually used
The crucial for this project was phc
pack so
when you have the situation where the
other junk floats around you want to
compute uh
you want to compute
the variety that you are interested in
which is a curve in the Taurus
and here you have to use phc pack
because that's well out of three things
were used that's the only Implement one
that has an implementation of polyhedral
homogapies
otherwise we could not move on
uh
well I mean for just sampling we can
everything was
executed inside of Macaulay 2 where we
have nice interfaces to all the other
things like PhD pack and bertinia
Virginia was particularly useful when we
drove things into singular situations
because there I mean the other
implementations use fixed Point
Precision at least for now and with
bertinia we were able to get more
accurate approximations of this leading
provisions of bizarre series giving us
Multiplicity
um so all together we used uh
all the available knowledge and software
in numerical algebraic geometry to get
uh
to get something that would work and
please one colleague of mine his name is
Stars garofalidis and and he is not
theorist
so our example will come our examples
come from
from topology from topology and not Siri
more precisely and this is exactly the
situation where some work has been done
but a lot of it stopped because we
cannot uh
people could not
get hands on this curve because it has a
lot of a lot of junk at the boundary of
the tours
so at the end of the day we are hoping
to compute some
some invariants of knots of
incompressible surfaces in in the
complements
um into in the complements of knots and
uh well that's the upshot of this
another upshot is certification of all
of this and
John is saying stop so I'm stopping
thank you
instances so when you talk about phc pad
then you have completed the sections
right so one what's a typical input
what's a typical eye so an eye where
this works well that's not a complete
resection well it turns out that
actually the examples supplied by
Stavros are complete intersections
but you can use this for non-complete
intersection the same way you are using
uh numeric algebraic from non-complete
intersections in the usual settings
moreover this scheme doesn't need to be
reduced you can use deflation and so on
I mean this is so under the carpet
you have to be sure that uh in the
Taurus there is a curve yes
do you I mean can you start with like a
witness that pricker witness that
representative of a curve or do you need
something more than that you need the
witness or preserve witness that
for curve
I think that's that's enough yeah that's
enough and that is actually the
bottleneck here because without phc pack
we would not we were not able to get
this witness set well also it looks like
what you're following here when you go
back to the original
theme is intersection of that curve with
that with a exponential hyper surface or
something right that's the average image
of a
or is it yeah yeah if you push it yeah
if you push this usual hyper surface and
lock coordinates up you're gonna get uh
yeah we're gonna get in it or just like
a translation of a subtory
there's a translation of a subtorus
it is a translation of the subtorus
it is algebraic I mean what a demands to
is computing
uh uh an intersection a slice of the
original thing with the hyper surface
this is given to you by a binomial
interfacing
yeah so actually I mean honors got
involved because he he's really hitting
the wall with the symbolics and uh
well I mean this is a symbolic fail in a
big way on those examples because you
cannot even produce the candidate Rays
the pre-variety there is not
one-dimensional for those examples that
we're interested in and the hope is that
uh well I mean the hope is that this is
a
bottom layer of computing higher
dimensional tropical varieties with this
technology because you always can
sort of intersect the tropical variety
and can consider links that are curves
things like that
no it's all it's in the paper there is a
big
future developments to page section of
all the future that could happen
where we made way with bigger examples
of knots that's why I say there is one
happy person
special all right thank you yeah
foreign